[Music]
uh oh party time i love being single i'm
really looking forward to it all the
apps getting on the apps yeah that's
gonna be cool swipe left swipe right
who's ugly
noah he was the love of my life damn it
that is the love of mine
it's like fully in new relationships
she's leaving me for a middle school
drama teacher can't take it with this
guy look at that bio artist
director
human oh you're a human man i bet he's a
chillhang
we can't give up we have to get them
back really think we can break them up
in like no time it's on
baby give me one more time you could
become noah's friend i'm extremely happy
make him realize that i am the one that
got away i could seduce logan i'm
wondering how you would feel about me
joining you in your bed yeah
ow this is like cruel intentions only
sexier
how is it sexier
it's not
okay get in there and turn his eye
are you ready to give all this up you
know popping bottles with the boys
grinding with the honeys you remind me
of that little singing uh cartoon gerbil
alvin the chipmunk yes okay yes
like a dermatologist dream
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i've never done molly
is my heart gonna explode no no you're
thinking a crack bro that's what it was
forget what happened
[Music]
can't believe we didn't think this part
all the way through we did not think
about that
[Applause]
i want you back
[Music]
bye